[موسيقى] لاعب
التنس الأمريكي المحترف السابق الذي تحول إلى عالم الأحياء في مجال
الحفاظ على البيئة، مايكل فيشباك
هو المؤسس المشارك لمنظمة The Great Whale
Conservancy، وهي منظمة مكرسة لحماية
سكان الحيتان، إن
الاضطراب المناخي الناتج عن النشاط البشري هو في الواقع ما هو تغير المناخ
حيث حدث 90 من الاحتباس الحراري،
أحب العمل معه  الأشخاص
المتحمسون والخبراء في ما
يفعلونه والذين يعرفون أنهم مستقلون قليلاً
ولا يخافون من القيام بالأشياء
بطريقتهم الخاصة،
ابنته دلفي ووترز هي أيضًا جزء
من الفريق الذي أتت به هنا
على متن القارب منذ أن كان عمرها ستة أشهر  قديم
ومنذ حوالي 10 سنوات بدأنا في
إجراء الأبحاث، كما
تعلمون كل ما تعلمناه
عن الحيتان الزرقاء في
منطقة لوريتو من مايكل ودلفي، ولكن
ليس الحيوان نفسه الذي
يبحثون عنه هذا الصباح بل هو
شيء نأمله  لقد تركت وراءك
اه حسنًا بوب، أرى ذلك يا إلهي، إن
العثور على طوب الحوت وجمع البراز هو مجرد
جزء واحد من روتينهم اليومي
عندما يكون في المنطقة الضوئية، فهو يحتوي على
حديد الفوسفور والنيتروجين
ويمتزج مع العناصر الغذائية الموجودة
فيه.  قاع المحيط الذي يتدفق إلى الأعلى
والذي يزدهر بالعوالق النباتية
بحيث يُخصب العوالق النباتية، لذا
فهذه هي مادة الحياة في المحيط حرفيًا
يشير مايكل إلى عملية تسمى
مضخة البئر أو بعبارة أكثر بساطة
في كل مكان أذهب إليه، أتحدث عن
حلقة البراز  تفرز الحيتان برازًا غنيًا بالمواد المغذية
التي تغذي العوالق
النباتية وهي كائنات صغيرة تشبه النباتات تساعد في مكافحة
تغير المناخ عن طريق امتصاص
كميات كبيرة من ثاني أكسيد الكربون من
الغلاف الجوي بينما تنتج في الوقت نفسه ما
لا يقل عن نصف الأكسجين على
الأرض،
وفي المقابل تغذي العوالق النباتية الكريل
والحيتان  ثم تناول الكريل ما يصل إلى
أربعة أطنان منه يوميًا وتستمر الدورة.
سيتم إرسال العينات التي يجمعونها إلى
المختبر حيث ستقيس الاختبارات
كميات المواد البلاستيكية الدقيقة في البراز
بالإضافة إلى الحصول على فكرة عامة عن
صحة الحيوان.
حول Wheels هو أنهم،
وخاصة الحيتان الزرقاء،
يهاجرون بوعي إلى منطقة يعرفون
تاريخيًا أنها ستتمتع
بارتفاع إنتاجي لمياه القاع، أعني أن الحيتان
عنصر حاسم ومكون واعٍ،
وهذا هو ما يختلف
عنهم في حياتنا اليومية، ونحن لا
نفكر  عن حيوانات مثل الحيتان أو
الفيلة
ومع ذلك فإن هذه الحيوانات تقدم
خدمات بيئية مهمة للإنسان من أجل
البقاء على كوكب الأرض
أجنبيًا